[Música]
la nasa reveló la imagen más profunda y
nítida del universo ha logrado hasta la
fecha fue tomada por el telescopio james
webb el más potente jamás lanzado del
espacio y sucesor del telescopio hubble
la presentación se realizó en la casa
blanca junto al presidente joe biden se
espera que nuevas imágenes del cosmos de
altísima calidad sean dadas a conocer el
martes
el presidente mexicano andrés manuel
lópez obrador llegó a washington para su
reunión de este martes con su homólogo
estadounidense joe biden el esperado
encuentro girará en torno a la migración
y a la inflación dos graves
problemáticas que golpean a ambas
naciones ampliamos desde la capital
mexicana
el uso de la mascarilla vuelve a ser
obligatorio en guatemala el fuerte
repunte en los contagios de kobe 19
llegó al gobierno de alejandro
giammattei a re imponer la restricción
ante el aumento de los casos en todo el
territorio nacional
bienvenidos a esta misión con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy valentina torres sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
eeuu la nasa reveló la que hasta el
momento es la imagen con mayor
resolución y detalle del universo
distante la fotografía es el resultado
del trabajo del telescopio james webb el
más avanzado lanzado del espacio se
trata de esta imagen del cúmulo de
galaxias sm acs 0723 que está llena de
detalles entre ellos miles de galaxias
la fotografía realmente es un compendio
de imágenes tomadas durante doce cinco
horas la masa combinada de este cúmulo
de galaxias actúa como una lupa debido a
su enorme fuerza gravitacional y
amplifica la luz infrarroja de estas
galaxias pasadas realmente conversamos
con diego mardones doctor en astronomía
de la universidad de harvard y académico
de la universidad de chile que nos
explicó lo que significa esta imagen
para la ciencia
hoy es emocionante pero lo más
importante que funciona no sé si ustedes
recordarán pero hacia el año 90 cuando
comenzó a observar el telescopio hubble
sus primeras imágenes fueron un desastre
porque estaba como desenfocado y costó
mucho tiempo arreglarlo y después de eso
hemos tenido 25 o 30 años de fotografías
maravillosas del telescopio espacial
hubble el james webb es la siguiente
etapa el hecho de cambiar luz óptica o
ultravioleta por infrarroja nos permite
ver más lejos nos permite el objeto más
ser más fríos planetas un universo que
está por descubrirse y estas imágenes
nos emociona muchísimo el presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador ya se
encuentra a washington y se reúne este
martes con su homólogo joe biden la
migración y la inflación dos temas que
golpean críticamente a ambas naciones
estarán en el centro del encuentro bario
carbón el corresponsal de france 24 en
ciudad de méxico nos amplió los detalles
pues sin duda el tema migratorio sera
al asunto abordar el presidente de lópez
obrador insiste en que el fenómeno
migratorio debe ser legalizado para
evitar tragedias como la ocurrida en
texas donde fallecieron varios
inmigrantes muchos de ellos mexicanos el
presidente lópez obrador planteara a
bailén que se ponga en práctica una
especie de arreglo como el que se vivió
en la década de los 40 del siglo pasado
con el presidente roosevelt que se
denominó programa bracero
lópez obrador dice que hay que reconocer
que hace falta fuerza de trabajo para
que crezca la economía de eeuu y que en
ese sentido vuelva a plantear que se
otorguen pizzas visas de trabajo para
que puedan los mexicanos ir a laborar a
eeuu
este será el principal tema sin embargo
también hablarán de la inflación dice
lópez obrador que va a llevar una
propuesta para enfrentar juntos esta
situación y que se apliquen políticas
bilaterales y no descarto asimismo a
abordar el tema de la seguridad en un
tema en que dice hay buena cooperación
entre los dos gobiernos de tal suerte
que bueno estos serán los temas
principales de lópez obrador ha enviado
un mensaje a los connacionales para
decirles que los va a defender defender
sus intereses en la casa blanca en eeuu
después de la decisión del tribunal
supremo de prohibir el aborto a nivel
federal muchos estadounidenses están
haciendo acopio de la pastilla de
emergencia o también llamada píldora del
día después la venta en algunos negocios
se ha multiplicado por cinco mam en sala
nos trae la historia
esta es nuestra área de recepción
cohen es uno de los propietarios de
estos almacenes donde venden productos
farmacéuticos como la pastilla del día
después la marca plan b está aquí tienen
hasta cinco marcas distintas y tenemos
más de la marca my shoes aquí porque
aquí se enteraron de que la corte
suprema había limitado el derecho al
aborto porque las ventas se dispararon
en su página web
nos levantamos y vimos cientos de
pedidos de pastillas de emergencia y fue
cuando dijimos algo no está bien
consultamos google y vimos la decisión
del supremo
desde entonces no hay descanso miles de
estadounidenses están comprando esta
píldora la gente está comprando está
almacenando porque no saben qué va a
pasar hoy ha sido el aborto pero mañana
podría hacer las pastillas de emergencia
lo que prohíben la gente quiere estar
preparada y si antes se compraba una
media de dos pastillas por cliente ahora
están acumulando y la media por pedido
es de cinco o seis cajas este es nuestro
chico de fe de escaneando los pedidos
cada día salen de este local 1200 cajas
5 es más que antes de conocerse el fallo
del supremo la mayoría con destino a los
estados más conservadores donde prohíben
el aborto ante el aumento de la demanda
algunas farmacias en el país como la que
ven detrás de mí han limitado el acceso
a esta pastilla a un máximo de tres por
cliente para evitar la escasez de
existencias por eso muchos
establecimientos la píldora se guarda
bajo llave como si fuese oro en otros ya
ni siquiera quedan y en la farmacia de
marta las cajas que hay también están
así de protegidas es increíble que
tengamos que vivir esto pero es un
reflejo del miedo que hay entre las
mujeres en esta sociedad porque no
sabemos qué va a pasar en un futuro y
por eso cohen ya se prepara este mes ha
doblado su pedido a los fabricantes de
píldoras para asegurar el stock del
producto más buscado por estos días en
eeuu el gobierno de guatemala reimpuso
el uso obligatorio de la mascarilla para
toda la población tras el aumento en los
casos de ccoo y 19 más de 18 mil
personas han perdido la vida por la
enfermedad en esta nación la cifra de
decesos más altas para un país
centroamericano andrés suárez jaramillo
los detalles fueron exactamente dos
meses los que guatemala estuvo libre del
uso obligatorio de la mascarilla del
tapabocas porque en mayo el ministro de
salud anunció que este país
centroamericano estaba listo para
relajar las medidas luego del de sesca
la mente en los casos de contagio sin
embargo ahora en julio una quinta ola de
la pandemia está impactando
negativamente la salud de los
guatemaltecos y las guatemaltecas y es
que haber derogado el uso obligatorio de
la mascarilla fue fuertemente criticado
por diferentes gremios de salud
incluyendo la asociación guatemalteca de
enfermedades infecciosas quien se apoyó
en el argumento de que guatemala es el
país con la menor tasa de vacunación de
la región estamos hablando de que apenas
un 35 por ciento de los guatemaltecos
están vacunados con un esquema de dos
dosis muy por debajo del 70 por ciento
recomendado por la organización mundial
de la salud para y relajar las medidas
ahora bien con este rebrote de los casos
de contagio de coronavirus el ministerio
de salud impuso nuevamente el regreso
obligatorio de la mascarilla tanto en
lugares cerrados como en lugares
abiertos y que cada municipalidad tiene
la potestad de imponer sanciones pero
esto se convierte en todo un reto por
ejemplo aquí en antigua donde este fin
de semana llegaron 50.000 turistas
nacionales y extranjeros y se convierte
en todo un reto para las autoridades
hacer que esta medida se cumpla
el gobierno de uruguay presentó un
recurso de apelación contra la sentencia
que obligó a suspender la vacunación
contra el hobbit 19 menores de 13 años
la semana pasada la justicia uruguaya
ordenó detener la inoculación hasta
conocer los contratos entre el estado y
la farmacéutica pfizer y la composición
de las sustancias del fármaco la medida
fue producto de un pedido de amparo
presentado por una abogada
y sigue fuera de control el enorme
incendio forestal al interior del parque
nacional yosemite y en eeuu el avance de
las llamas amenaza a la comunidad o
abona un bosque de secuelas gigantes de
mariposa el fuego ya ha afectado unas
930 hectáreas de bosque nativo
entretanto los equipos de bomberos
informaron que habían logrado establecer
algunas líneas de contención de las
llamas en algunos puntos clave la
conflagración denominada el incendio
washburn comenzó en la tarde del jueves
cerca de la entrada sur del parque sin
que se conozca su origen
fin del informativo los invitamos a
seguir con toda nuestra programación y a
visitar nuestra página web france24
puntocom
[Música]